you
[Music]
all right so it's my pleasure to
introduce in the bozhe Nevada I would
say is probably our resident
probabilistic and graphical modeling and
Bayesian inference in that whole world
of statistics experts so if you have any
questions in that area he's a great
person to talk to and learn learn
everything that he knows in that area
and today he'll be talking about land
cover map D&I project Lee he's been
working on for a little bit and should
be really interesting thank you
so yeah I'll talk about land cover
mapping that's not the only thing that I
do I do natural language processing
experiments mentioned and gravitational
biology as well and computer vision
basically anything that you might think
you can solve with machine learning I
might be interested in land cover
mapping is something we started a couple
of years ago as part of our AI fourth
initiative which started the MSR and
then moved to Cielo and since then
there's been quite a few people that we
worked with from Silla this Lukas joppa
who is running in AI fourth over there
then Maurice who used to be an MSR and
was interested in mostly wildlife
detection and classification but then he
moved full-time to AI fourth and then he
also started working with us on land
cover mapping and then there was a
number of current and former interns
over the last couple years as well as
now to our resident sandy and Blake and
then lots of external collaborators I
just mentioned some here and I'm really
bad at putting faces on the slides
however the interns did this for a
different talk so I have some of the
faces here and this is how I'm gonna
organize a talk first there will be a
relatively lengthy introduction
hopefully not too long because I want to
want to be the problem a little bit
because it's surprisingly versatile and
useful for a variety of machine learning
projects that you might be pursuing in
other domains and then I'll talk about
our main goal that we started with which
was creating the first u.s. wide one
meter land cover map which resulted in
two publications and a map that's going
to be publicly available in a week when
the papers published in cvpr and the
demo
as well and then I'll talk about a
couple of ideas we've been exploring
this summer and some are actually
already under review and some are just
starting really and then finally if I
have time I'll mention some applications
of collaborations with outside entities
as well as open problems so I'll start
with where we were a couple years ago we
decided that we should take this label
data set that Chesapeake Conservancy
created and this was data set where for
about 160,000 kilometers squared
they have labeled every square meter
with one of a few labels such as water
tree canopy low vegetation house Road
and so on and then the idea was if we
train a model on this can we then use
that model and map the entire United
States and create a first map of that
kind so you start with something that's
2 or 3 percent of the territory and then
you spread it on the entire United
States it is interesting that Chesapeake
actually spent 10 months creating this
dataset it costed them 1.3 million
dollars they didn't do it for us they
did it because they needed the labels
this is the interesting thinking in this
work is that the labels are actually
goal in particular area the algorithm is
sort of a nice if you can transfer but
they really want the labels in the area
so they did it to control the water
quality to inform conservation efforts
and so on so it costed them that much
now the question is can you do this in a
much cheaper way using machine learning
and how this is what their data looks
like so this is the Chesapeake watershed
and they've taken broken this whole
thing into tiles and then one of these
tiles would look something like this the
image on the left is the so-called nape
image from national agriculture imagery
program it has RGB but also need near-ir
channels and the labels are on the
right-hand side if we zoom in a little
more you can see what quality of the
labels we might see it doesn't show all
this
we might get but you can see some some
things like a break in the road here
often the roads are actually classified
as water because they're kind of cold
and sometimes have similar color as the
water and then you might miss some of
the small built features and so on
however you can see it's a highly crisp
very precise map where you can see
individual houses driveways you can
actually see cars in these images so of
course the goal then is if we take a lot
of pairs of images like this can I just
train a segmentation at work that will
then be capable of taking any image of
this kind and produce the appropriate
labels for every pixel in the image and
before I talk about all the troubles in
doing this I should also mention why we
want to do this so one is change
detection for example you want to
monitor urban sprawl and if you just
look at how much the image has changed
from one year to another it doesn't
really tell you much because the change
is large because the texture change but
you have to have to actually classify
this and realize whether or not there
was actually a land-use change so then
if you can actually use predictions that
might help realize that actually it's
not what something was built here and
then Chesapeake was particularly
interested in analyzing riparian buffers
which are these interfaces between water
and land because that that informs them
about the quality of the water if you
don't have enough vegetation and have
too much built nearby then you might
have run off and that will ruin the
quality of the water and of course it
will ruin the habitat for fish and so on
but for whatever I ative reasons they
really care about these buffers then of
course you could be looking at the
afforestation when a new neighborhood is
built do they cut more trees than they
promised these are the sort of things
that are sometimes really hard to tell
unless you go to the high resolution
like like here if you have a high
resolution map versus what we used to
have everywhere United States these low
resolution labels at 30 meters it is
hard to see some of these things now
on the issue with labels I should
mention that this is the sort of a label
that label quality that we get from
Chesapeake and if you stare a little bit
you can see in this area there are
errors that some of the impervious
surfaces were classified as water you'll
see that also in the road here but
they're very high-resolution and you see
quite quite a bit of what's going on
there the National Land cover database
has labels at 30 meter resolution and
they look like this for that same area
and you have more classes not just the
four hours showing but you've got also
classes that are kind of mixed they will
tell you that there is a certain
percentage of built in in a in in a
block so they'll break all the urban
blocks into low-density high-density
medium density and open space with
different percentages of impervious
surfaces and vegetation and then there
are some classes like snow and ice or
classes like Prairie or class like
agricultural land versus low vegetation
brush and so on several twenty twenty
classes and they're usually mixed but
they're very low resolution like you can
see here and also we get these only
every few years back when we were
working on this last summer we only had
a map that was seven years old and then
Christmastime they came up with two more
for 2013 and 2016
but anyway anyways you get you get them
early and also here you can see mistakes
as well that I mean if you stare at them
there's a lot of mistakes that that are
being made on these maps as well but
that's the best we we have in terms in
terms of the labels now the difference
is that these are available everywhere
in itíd states and the Chesapeake labels
only in Chesapeake watershed so that's
the sort of a problem that you deal with
but if you pop up a level and think
about what are all the possible things
people might be doing with these sort of
data you will have different types of
images at different resolutions
different logics on all the frequency of
sampling them
Landsat for example is public it
provides 30 million images on a weekly
basis
but it's 30 meter not 1 meter that's the
input not the output the nlcd is
actually based on land set that's why
it's 30 meters label data is sparse and
it's usually at low resolution as I
mentioned about nlcd and that the tasks
can vary a lot
Chesapeake actually has realized that
they really wish they had included
wetlands in their set of classes so now
they want to work with us on redoing the
wetland classification and in fact
various collaborators Ducks dot-com
that's a that I think that that's what
they call tax com they're actually into
hunting ducks so they want to maintain
wetlands they're interested in this but
then also know is interested in tracking
wetland destructions in the Gulf for
everybody who went to hi-c hi-c LRD the
other a couple of weeks ago you've
learned about New Orleans slowly sinking
precisely because they're controlling
where the water goes New Orleans has
more canals than Venice and they don't
allow anything to be too moist and so
the whole area is settling and sinking
down because there's no new mud to come
in and cover everything and so the
wetlands are being destroyed and then
you know a hurricane or two and then
things get changed vary quite a bit and
nobody knows the extent of it and they
would like to track that and then you
might want to map coffee farms that's a
different category in developing world
they want to map resources because they
actually even for building in roads they
don't know what they are because there's
a lot of wall building in Africa they
want to also find where the buildings
are but because they want to know where
the population is so they know where
they are when they need to get to them
and then you have disaster response when
you have flooding and so on so the task
certifications are varied and labels can
be totally different from what we have
right now and the important thing is
that you get actually extra six
terabytes of imagery per day just from
one of the companies that provides this
data planetlab
and pilot labs launched their first
satellite in 2013 so this is all very
recent this explosion imagery that you
can get there are other companies Airbus
is May
King drone imagery and then there are
startups that are planning to actually
have video rate imagery for for a region
that you've asked for in advance but
they'll imagery for most things so we
are maybe Euro or two away from having
daily imagery of the entire planet
and right now planet is pretty close
planet lab is pretty close they might
have weekly instead of daily now this is
a surprising thing Blake asked what is
the market size for GIS or geospatial
and lytx and then Anthony one of the
previous interns found this market
report where they say that the current
market size is 41 billion dollars and in
by 2023 it's gonna be 86 billion dollars
which was a bit surprising to me
in comparison cloud is 272 billion and
it's going to be 623 by 2023 and AI
software is 9.5 billion will be 71
billion by 2023 now predicting AI impact
is is you know black magic because you
can get somebody predicting 1 billion
and somebody predicting 8 trillion
depending on what they actually take
into account and I'm not saying that we
should be doing geospatial index because
there's money in it and because it makes
us feel good because you know wine
industry is underneath billion and it
will be four hundred fifty billion
dollars however I remember when Jim Gray
gave a talk in front of Craig Mundy
about his work on moving all these data
from the Astronomy community on to the
sequel server and he started to talk by
astronomy is a zero billion dollar
industry
well geospatial it exists not it's it's
pretty big industry and in fact prog
groups if Microsoft are looking into
into these areas in Azure and also in
Bing and if you actually bought that
report instead of just looking the
highlights like I did then they would
break it by type and I don't know how is
broken by type but I thought I'd show
you these types so surface and feel
analytics network and location oolitic
geovisualization
then by application they break it into
surveying medicine and Public Safety
Disaster Risk Reduction and Management
climate change adaptation and then by
vertical business you know banks
insurance companies Wall Street and
automotive utility communication
government defense and intelligence
Natural Resources I just read those to
you so you can sort of you can imagine
how and where these things would be used
but when we talk to our collaborators we
found that there is this bootstrap
problem so land cover mapping is
labor-intensive and and is therefore
very expensive you have to buy this
software which is expensive you have to
learn how to use it and then you have to
spend time the reason why Chesapeake
spent 1.3 million dollars in ten months
is because they do start with computer
vision algorithms they will run a
computer vision algorithm that will
segment the image into little polygons
and then these polygons are being
classified based on shape and color and
variation in color and that gives an
approximate map but then they go in and
by hand fix it up and then some somehow
if they're very skilled
there are ways of using different rules
for classification different areas so
they will hand tune those and say if if
this is south facing then you should use
this rule but if it's North facing heel
side of the hill then you should use
this rule and so on so it takes a while
and so then if a less well-funded
agency realize that that there is
actually all this satellite data that
they could see a lot of things that
would be difficult for them to keep
track by surveying otherwise going door
to door and figuring out what's going on
going into the forest and mapping it and
they would like to use satellite imagery
which is only a few weeks old or a few
months old the problem is they have to
buy the imagery and they have to then
spend money labeling it and they don't
really know what they're going to get
out of it so there's a bootstrap problem
so all of these numbers from previous
slides got put into perspective that if
you can somehow bring down the cost of
this process dramatically then there
will be many new applications that
aren't even foreseen yet so back to the
king of the united states at 1 meter
resolution the main problem is that this
area here is lush and green full of
forests and the rest of United States is
not necessarily like that
so there's training on this actually
turns out to do relatively well here
where we are but not here and not in the
swamp either so
so this problem really becomes a domain
adaptation problem in a sense rest of
the u.s. looks very different and there
are no labels and of course the desire
levels themselves may change if you want
to do wetlands so then how do we adapt
to retrain the models that we trained
maybe in Chesapeake what sort of
guidance that we use so you can refer to
in terms of you know these are the
things like you know mental learning
learning to learn and learning to forget
forgetting to learn whatever and they're
all sort of the same problem right and
because of that and because of the all
these growing applications there's now
rapid rapidly growing interest in the
machine learning research community last
year at cvpr there was a workshop and a
challenge on land cover mapping and and
then various machine many groups are
starting to get into this Milla has
hired postdocs and interns to work on
that actually one of their entrance was
our intern to afterwards so there's a
lot of interest now ramping up in this
so now after this lengthy introduction
I'll talk about a couple of things we
have done so first I'll talk about label
super-resolution so our goal as I
mentioned is you have this high
resolution satellite imagery and every
pixel is one meter squared and you also
have these high resolution land cover
maps that well you want to produce
something of this quality however you
don't really have that data everywhere
you only have it in a small amount on
amount of the United States but you do
have this data everywhere so now the
question is can we use these low
resolution labels only and still create
models they can they can predict Hyrule
labels so in other words you've got
you've got one meter imagery and 30
meter land-cover labels these and you
want to predict one meter land-cover
labels so just using these these things
you want to predict that even if you've
never seen an example of a
high-resolution I'll land cover map so
how would you do that so if you're going
to use a semantic segmentation network
for example like this is a unit that we
used and the way the unit works is that
you have a couple of convolutional
layers and then you have some up
sampling pooling and up sampling and
then you keep doing this until they have
a compact representation of the entire
image and then you go backwards and up
sample and then there are these lateral
connections as well that help you not
blur the edges too much and so on and we
tried initially several different
methods and this one seemed to work the
best the unit on the high resolution
predictions on the high resolution data
so a network that will predict high
resolution data would look like this we
might predict these sort of segments
this kind of segmentation for this image
but we don't and and if we were to train
on just a pic then we would simply have
a cross entropy pixel wise comparison
the actual high-resolution ground truth
is this and not that so you have a send
a signal back that all these blue areas
are actually supposed to be impervious
surface but if you don't have that to
guide you but you have low resolution
ground truth there's still something you
can do you can look in each one of these
blocks and then compare that block to
what's what the counts of features are
sorry counts of labels are in this block
what percentage of this block is water
what percentage is field what percentage
is forest and what percentage is
impervious and then compare with what
you would expect in a block of this type
of this type of block in in in nlcd
because these blocks actually have
descriptions so this is called developed
low end
in intensity this type of block and it
would expect 30% for is 34% field and
35% built then in the medium intensity
will have 64% built and developed up in
space you can have only 12% built so
then if you can create a cost associated
with you know these blocks here should
expect to see this proportion of the
counts of labels in here and in here
then you can actually create you can
create a a cost that are lost they can
minimize so you count simply the labels
here and compare them to be the expected
counts for the label there and you can
back propagate was there hand done they
are done just like everything in this is
you use machine learning algorithms and
then you find and any fix them by hand
so and you're finding these doesn't seem
so difficult for a person to you oh all
these yeah the definitions there in here
in here these are definitions that are
based on the statistics we find in
Chesapeake alright so interests we can
you can fine-tune these this is but this
is that they they give are different
they're they're more like between five
and 20 percent for this and between 20
and 40 percent for this and something
like that right and you can use those as
well
but we use the ones we fine-tuned in
Chesapeake so for 20 different classes
we have these distributions and then we
use those everywhere in the United
States now the so you have predictions
at 1 meter now you make the model
predict X actual label so for classes
and then you'll find summarization at 30
meter and compares the ground truth at
30 meters so if you want to look at it
more as a block you do have a semantic
simulation network it does take one
meter resolution image X and outputs 1
meter resolution label image y
but then in every 30 by 30 block you
count the labels when you count the
labels actually since these are probably
stick predictions anyways coming out of
softmax then you're also counting you
also estimating the variance of your
counts
that's what we're sending here like as a
distribution the mean and the variance
around all of these things which is very
important already in the learning and
then you match that with the statistics
you would expect from the low res label
and then you can propagate things back
and train them all and once you've
trained the model you can do two things
you can throw all this out and just use
Matic simulation network to make these
predictions or you can if you do have
labels in a new area you can also try to
find these so that they best represent
whatever semantics imitation wants that
Network once and what the signal from
here would be the counts are into
integers but the output here is
probability of every label so then when
you add up these probabilities you're
going to actually get the mean the
expected number of pixels of a certain
label but there's also variance which is
the sum of P times 1 minus P so so then
so that's a thematic point this is how
they defined the class 22 developed low
intensity impervious 22:49 the city is
forest is there has more than 20% of
trees and fields at the rest so this
this is the this is what you came back
propagate if you don't want to use the
fine-tuned distribution from Chesapeake
so then you have these two images and
I'm going to represent this nlcd image
in terms of these distributions so I
actually just averaged all that for
classes in here to represent that
expectation so I can show you this thing
is in sort of as a distribution over
what's happening in each of these locks
and then we train them all as I
described it and this is what you have
but then if I look at a few iterations
gradient descent and look at the soft
map that's when I actually look at the
full distribution P of Y given the input
rather than just the maximum the Arg max
then you get something like this you can
still see the block structure from the
nlcd but then very quickly you start to
get these features even though they're
wrong a lot of the fields are so a lot
of the road is is classified as field
and then over a while after a while you
start to actually get appropriate
distributions and this is sort of what
you end with and this is what we started
with so so this then allows us to do
quite well in the rest of the United
States and the we call this label super
resolution because you have labels at
low resolution input is at high
resolution and you resolve the labels at
the high resolution too and actually
it's a general technique so you can use
it elsewhere we in the iclear paper we
use it for pathology images as well
where pathologies have found that it's
easy for them to label blocks and even
use machine learning algorithms that
predict them what the probability of
lymphocyte intrusion is in every one of
these blocks and they do that well but
they can't quite get the features and we
can of course in the same way use these
two to super resolve and find these
lymphocytes yeah you do well because you
don't really have yeah I'll get to that
yeah it's a good question yeah so of
course in the in the paper what we did
was we we just try to train on the South
of Chesapeake and predict the north of
Chesapeake we have labels so you can
make these predictions so we have the
numbers but how well how do we know how
what we're doing the United States that
that's a harder question I notice not
wait for everything but this is a huge
data coming from the Open Street Map
community mm-hmm that can be used as a
prior to and I wondered how will you do
that yeah so we have used also data from
being Maps they have labeled building
footprints in the United States so
that's helpful and we can use their open
street maps as well we don't have open
street maps everywhere though so we were
studying how you could create
the map that there applies everywhere
and the other thing with the
OpenStreetMaps is they're really
interested in roads and buildings
sometimes but not so much in the
vegetation discrimination and that's
part of that all it takes for the
community is a good motivation and they
would yeah gives an arm let's go and
you'll see it by the end I'm going to
get into that too yeah okay so so then
arm with label super-resolution you can
imagine that now we can try and map
entire United States and and we did that
we have some high res labels here low
res labels everywhere about 50 terabytes
of data
hmm pixels and then you do a simple
thing which is your training a network
like this a small unit for the entire
United States and then where we have
high resolutely balls we use
cross-entropy where we don't we use
super resolution and we train the whole
thing with sample patches of land all
over United States and use super super
Earths loss there and sample patches
from the Chesapeake and use high res
loss the thing is that you don't
actually get much from training on all
the data use sample patches because the
data is actually sort of redundant which
is going to be important or later but
you can imagine that if you have a pixel
that's labeled for you and it's in the
middle of a road then getting bunch more
which are almost identical is not going
to help you much and the same in the
field or water and so on so sampling
patches is usually better than taking
the entire tired tile and training on
the entire tile then we did some other
tricks like augmentation we use
additional inputs multiple time point
land sets leaf on leaf off images and
then train the mob is under trained as I
said because your training this small
model for the entire United States we
didn't really we didn't know quite how
much we're supposed to sample in fact
inference took much longer than the
training I think about ten days on 40
GPUs and so we ended up with a map now
how good is the map well we don't know
but but what we can do is we can say
well let's see given that we are
sampling at random and not covering
everything that it does make sense to
just
compute the agreement of our map we
didn't see the labels everywhere and
double reveal issues and you can see
issues wherever it's dark is pretty good
it's dark here it's dark where we are
but in the rural sort of Heartland there
are things that the model has has never
seen in the high-resolution here we
maybe didn't sample enough there in four
with the nlcd loss dry area dry areas
are sometimes badly classified this is
Roswell New Mexico so we don't have data
and I don't know what happened here but
by and large it's the first of its kind
it's gonna be public people might be
using it actually there were some people
at Microsoft who used it already for
interesting applications in in CS CSS
yeah you know what there's some like
blocky things kind of nervous yes the
blocks the fuzzy data issues no III
think and correct me if I'm wrong but I
think this is the NAIP imagery so these
planes that are flying over the United
States they take couple of years to
actually cover everything and not every
state is being captured at the same time
and so they'll do it do it
state-by-state and so you'll see the
state boundaries actually sometimes in
these things because these models are
very sensitive to changes in the input
distribution okay so now the question is
we have these low res labels that we can
use them the way I described but as I
mentioned maybe doing this dance
prediction and having dense prediction
data even a low resolution is maybe not
necessary because point labels might be
enough maybe I just need four hundred
points in a patch rather than the entire
thing labeled so then that's another
approach we can do point labels which
are vocation precise precise in terms of
location at one meter or close to one
meter but maybe possibly having direct
label district descriptions what I mean
by that is there's a lot of geotag stuff
out there and they're kind of giving you
with descriptions or without
descriptions they're kind of giving you
the idea what might be there
where you took the photo for example but
they're gonna be very sparse and so the
next thing I'm gonna briefly talk about
is something we haven't done much with
but we're starting to and that's I
naturally species of reservations I'm
going to talk about hybrid intelligence
approaching stole and cover mapping
where you actually kind of get both
towards evaluating and using these fine
labels and some more interesting things
so I naturalist is this well it's a
website it's an organization where when
you take a photo of something wildlife
in particular the interest in wildlife
anything a flower a bug an eagle you
take a photo you upload it to their
website with a label and so they keep
track of all of these things and if you
don't know what it is there's a
community that's gonna try to label it
for you and you actually get a lot of
labels everywhere in the world for
example in Chesapeake watershed you have
these 63,000 observations in the United
States as a whole you've got this it's
sort of funny finally it looks a lot
like our quality map it says so but what
does that look like so you can actually
look if you go to that website you can
look underlying world imagery layer so
you can see where the what I think was
sampled so here somebody has taken a
photo right there and this is
interesting because our models often
mistakes water for road especially if
it's white water but the label there is
oh it's from the order of Pacific salmon
routes in fact there's an image there
and there's even a description that it
says it's a it's a it's a salmon right
so you should know that it's not it's
not a road and then if you look at the
sightings of seagulls and fish eating
eagles you see them often close to the
water on the edge so that should be
informative and Eli who's working on
this project this summer has looked at
some distributions for brown pelican
chaparral which is some sort of a brush
I guess sage or something and Belton
Kingfisher and you can see the different
type
so LCD labels where do you find these
things and they different distributions
you can embed those distributions and
you can then here every species every
circulating species and it's colored by
the predominant were a terrain type that
you find them but you can see that sort
of there is some sort of a finer
embedding into the these types things
that are on the interface urban
interface between water and and concrete
and actually if you look at a more dense
dense a picture of things you can start
to see that actually we have very
different types of land and we could be
getting predictions that are more
fine-grained than then even nlcd is in
terms of the labels because we actually
have very different habitat habitat so
knowing which sort of mushrooms people
have seen in the forest which sort of
bugs and which sort of animals can
create a new type so type of land cover
map or land cover index and and so this
gives rise to some interesting ideas
regarding unsupervised land cover
mapping and then here's this idea of
using hybrid intelligence approaches
land cover mapping and the question here
well there many questions here but you
can start with this one how many new
point labels do we actually need based
on what I was telling you that maybe we
don't need to sample densely get the
dense map of the entire image in order
to Train it we just need a couple of
points how many's couple so if he asks
humans to label hundreds of thousands of
points and it turns out they can label
about 300 points in 15 minutes so then
can you now readapt your model maybe not
by retraining the whole thing but
retraining the last K layers of the
model or searching for a drop-off
configuration that matches where you
just randomly arrays outputs of certain
neurons and then search for a
configuration of these erasers that
optimally damages the brain as young
econ would say so that it actually
starts seeing that a road is a road not
as a water then we also experiment with
group norm parameter annotation where
you are actually just taking
a groups of filters and changing them in
concert by just scaling them and
shifting them and you can of course do a
lot of different other things but then
the question is if you also retrain them
all on the fly as labels labels are
using it if they can see the effect of
their work then maybe this will further
increase sample efficiency as humans
find better points to label this is sort
of what machine teaching people well you
know emphasize and and so we've done
something like that this is gonna play
yeah so I'm gonna show you this funny
video that Andy and Caleb have made
where they have oh there's no music so
you won't hear the music music is
awesome too but they've made this it's
very self-explanatory very short so I'm
not gonna I'm not going to talk
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so hopefully you get the idea
so so you'll get the idea because I'm
supposing that you do because and you
actually read this study on Mechanical
Turk and that was the instructions that
they got and they were able to do it so
so basically the idea here is that you
get to choose where you want to test the
model and you get to choose what you
want to correct and you don't even have
to correct a mistake because the model
doesn't know where the mistake is
anyways you can pre can even you can
reconfirm whatever the model is
predicting you do whatever you want
essentially and then the hope is that
with this interaction you're going to
get to a good fine-tuning of the model
faster then you would with other tools
the other tool would be normal
crowdsourcing where the system is asking
users to label particular things and by
showing them the petrol van and say what
is that and that's what we've compared
with before we did all these comparisons
we first did an offline analysis Blake
and Anthony ran a study where they asked
the question if we do different
adaptation methods we can fine-tune the
last layer or last two layers the last
three layers we can do this with norm
thing or drop out we had some other
ideas too but this was expensive enough
to try all of those things then how many
training points do you need before you
start doing well and so they tried up to
2,000 points and they got these curves
with significance level significance
bands and you can see that fine-tuning
lost two layers and lost three layers is
basically the best and they're
essentially indistinguishable they're
equally good which is why we chose one
of the Taoiseach methods in our tool to
be the last two layers but last one
layer is quite a bit different method
much much faster because in the way we
implement it is that last one layer
would be trained all the way to two
fitting perfectly the hole the hole the
the all the data that's given where
these last two layers would only run for
a certain number
and to look in terms of computation they
reached last one layer and so we decided
to test those two things for the users
and then what we are showing here on the
left is comparison of all these methods
but when we use random query method
which means that they sampled at random
points from a tile in New York and and
then they would take a model based model
was trained in Maryland and based on the
labels that we have in New York because
that part is that that part of New York
is in the Chesapeake watershed then they
would retrain that top layer or top two
layers and see how well it does over
time with more and more points and then
the graph here shows what would happen
if you use the last two layers only this
this method here that worked fairly well
and then try different ways of selecting
points instead of randomly selecting
them you can select them using the
entropy method which is the traditional
thing in active learning mean margin
which is basically looking at the
difference between the predicted class
and the next most likely class and then
we even use the method which we called
mistakes which is if the model somehow
magically knew where it was wrong and
sampled points only where the mistakes
are what would happen of course in
active learning you don't you can do
that you don't know what the mistakes
are the reason why we did that is we
wanted to see if the users are doing
basically just being able to detect the
mistakes and then choosing these
mistakes at random well it turns out
that doing that is going to be worse
than random or entropy or that then
random or mean margin now random a mean
margin mean margin was slightly better
but not that much better and all these
curves can change quite a bit when you
go from one area to another area so we
decided to go with a random in our tests
and just test how well we do compared to
the random method and this is kind of
known in active learning literature and
machine teaching literature that it's
very difficult to design an active
learning
tragedy that does better than just
randomly choosing points for labeling
now our yeah when you find you know
small local patch um that means it
generalizes better across the entire
dataset oh yeah that's right so here
you're training with two thousand points
but you're testing on the entire tile
yeah that's what that let's go here you
have only a few thousand points or a few
hundred points and then you test on the
entire tile and the question is how many
of these do you need and don't know the
entire that entire area so it was 85
kilometers squared and so they're
supposed to spend 15 minutes on the 85
kilometers squared and do as well as
they can and in these offline sort of
simulations to see what would be what
would happen if we actually tell them
where to label rather than let them
label what they want
so in our study Andy who became an
expert Mechanical Turk studies because
of her work with H a so she she ran
these studies on turquoise with 95
percent approval and each would work 15
minutes in each of the four different
areas in New York State and then they
always start with the same base model
pre trained in Maryland and then they
would work with two other patient
methods but they didn't know that the
first three tasks were with one addition
method and the last we would switch the
rotation method on them without telling
them and all of this is happening
randomized orders and the reason why we
did this is we thought the first task
the first fifteen minutes is basically
time where they learn how to use the
tool and then between the second and
third task we can see what are what are
there is actually expertise being built
what did they stay what people were
doing well in the second task is are
also people who didn't volunteer tasks
where there's a skill differentiation
and then the switching and the fourth
task wouldn't see how did they react
when actually that thing that they were
working with and they might have been
building a theory of mind of changes or
are they just going around finding
errors and clicking and so first of all
humans if you look at where they
actually work
this is across all 50 users these are
not random places as you can tell
they're drawn to some things they do
better than random so if we tell them if
you randomly choose points everywhere
and ask them to label them they're not
going to get as far in terms of mean iou
as they do when they get to choose what
they want to do these are the confidence
intervals here and this is the sort of
the best user and what's also
interesting is that of the top 25 users
in the second task 17 are also in the
top 25 the third task so it's not random
these results are not random there's
variation among people part of it is
because of their interest in the task or
skill but then the correlation breaks in
the fourth area so you can't predict
who's going to do well in the fourth
area based on how well they did in third
area which indicates that there is this
theory of mine going on that people
actually understand what they're doing
and they kind of understand the model in
fact most people commented in the post
asked interviews that there was a change
and they would call one of the model
sluggish they would say well he was kind
of sluggish until the last task or they
would say it was great until the last
task then it became sluggish and it was
kind of mind-boggling to Caleb who
didn't see how how could they see the
difference but when you play with this
for 15 minutes you see that it's not
reacting to you and you kind of start
building ideas why and how they can't
quite put it all in words but it was
clear to us that they actually were
getting the idea what what's happening
behind these adaptations this is another
interesting thing although this is sort
of you know there's an asterisk here so
I said Chesapeake Conservancy spent 1.3
million dollars doing this if we are to
believe this 485 kilometer squared areas
when we played with then it seems like
our best user would be able to do that
for eighteen point five thousand dollars
in 925 hours and with not much big a
drop of any accuracy so we are hoping to
get some other sort of numbers to see
how much we can actually lower the cost
so the next thing that's really exciting
the summer is the idea of not having
every user working on their own but
having them all working collaboratively
on a large area and then you have all
kinds of interventions you can play with
like you can show heat maps to users you
can for example show them this you know
where people are working how does that
help you can also play with letting
users share the workload so the one user
works for a while and then it get tired
of it and want to work on another area
the other user can take over and various
other things one thing that we found is
that that 85 kilometers Square area
might have been too big for our
detection method so then the question is
what is the right size you would have a
different model obviously in every one
of these areas where people are working
so you end up having this spatial
ensemble where there's different model
in different areas so you could do that
automatically in the sense that you
could say there is M models possibly
with some trainable parameters and then
you're learning a spatial mapping
function that map's lat/long into a
weight distribution or models and you
can mix these models either in the
parameter space or in the prediction
space and you can do backdrop through
the whole example and then the final
thing we want to do is sort of a
collaboration challenge again we're
bringing a lot of people working in this
tool to to label things and the mob is
automatically adapting but we also want
to bring machine learning teams from
various labs to put in their models and
so we would have sort of a workshop
where we're going for the collaboration
challenge where we're trying to map as
much as possible rather than see who's
the best SID yeah by allowing the
workers to collaborate
just increase speed efficiency it could
be you could decrease be they could ISM
in court in G Carson it could and and
then we would then we would not do that
later good but it would be a result
right would like to know part like where
you had loved those plots for your
random and Traviata found so I was
wondering if you were to do like you
know this vision neural network style
like basically like thinks neural
networks which bootstrap GP thing and
then do your like you know usual thing
of like value of labeling a point
approximate like value of information
yeah would that have any chance against
random or in sir or is that wrong nor do
so we don't know because we haven't
tried and actually we should Kayla we
should try this
I can also mention that we should
basically use Bayesian ensemble sorry
dropout Bayesian example or some other
or bootstrap just train five models and
see what a they they're all uncertain in
the same place so these are the
uncertain points so we don't know this
for sure how it will work we know from
previous literature that whenever you
think you can actually get the active
learning to work you it becomes hard and
we also know from recent literature in
neural networks that training on that
it's not very intuitive on which sort of
samples you're supposed to train there
was a I clear paper on these forgettable
unforgettable
samples for instance and that might
inform you about what you're supposed to
be training on but by and large I don't
know it seems though the humans have no
problem with it and they spend the same
amount of time actually working out two
or crowd sourcing on their own this is a
role for simulation to help with this
for refused error sent to Brazil to
simulate the earth vegetation l banks
and then we can put a realistically
simulate the world and then you have a
perfectly labeled infinite resolution
sandbox you might work my knee-jerk
reaction if you ask me this five years
ago I would say well no I mean it's fake
data so you get a fake result but these
are getting so good and people are
getting boost from using this data
another application so it
might work it would be very expensive
from the computational side of a point
point of view but actually what is most
expensive currently is labor anyway so
some it might make sense to try yeah
there's a problem with the air sink
approach that you will have to solve
before because person really doesn't
have you need to model the atmosphere on
how if the image would look like from
very high above and the game engines are
not super optimized for that like you
will have to build in like like actually
the new flight sim might actually be
better that way right because they
actually are modeling how a thing will
look like from 6,000 feet or 10,000 feet
or 30,000 feet right right whereas we
are basically an air sim relying on
unreal as the rendering engine right so
you will have to do special things yeah
so so anyhow the the spatial and sample
I was talking about would look something
like this we're trying to get to this
sort of classification of the image and
this is the image you have and now some
people working here and some people
working there so people working here
some people working there or whatever
where they want to work then you have
this constellation of models they're all
being refined but they refine to find
the areas where they work then Caleb ran
this example this morning and they sort
of segment the jurisdiction like this
automatically were one more like she
takes most of the area but then two
others are kind of modeling this other
place and that's by learning that
lat/long to model mapping function and
if you have that long to model mapping
function and then use this distribution
or models inside your prediction then
the whole thing is differentiable so you
can train both of these things but
different models and predictions now
this spatial ensemble isn't something
that you can now apply somewhere else
it's just a way for you to get as fast
as you can to the labeling of that area
and this is what's different between
this approach is sort of general machine
teaching approach because the goal isn't
to create necessarily a best model
that's going to work everywhere although
if that happens great you can reuse some
of these models in other places as
starting points but the goal is to get
the labels that's what people want and
and the goal is to reduce the amount of
Labor that people do to get there so
it's more of a sort of a hybrid
intelligence method than the machine
teaching method
now the collaborations that we have we
would like to do some additional studies
with Chesapeake and Noah and Ducks on
wetlands mapping and we have some ideas
how to do it without labels without with
just some loose guiding guidance from
nlcd and also with that tool that I
showed you you can just as easily add a
new label and start learning new new
things and we've tested that a little
bit with Chesapeake then we're working
World Bank and municipal governments in
Miramar and Vietnam on their resource
mapping problem because that's another
example where you have a government
doesn't have enough funds can you drop
drop the costs of labor so much down
that they can just do it you're using a
tool like this and then make sure you
have various internal products and CSS
collaborations I'm not even sure what is
confidential what's not but there is
interest in Microsoft in in this
business now regarding the open problems
there's a lot of problems with this
collaborative mapping and humans in the
loop and they're fascinating if you're
actually creating the system where
humans are not not in your network then
they are how do you analyze these things
how do you build the best ones as Sid
said maybe the collaboration makes
things worse it's interesting too and
also what is the human supposed to be
doing in this are we supposed to tell
people who to work with and what to work
on or are they supposed to somehow self
select what works the best and then in
terms of machine learning one big thing
is unsupervised pre-training the models
that we pre trained were pre trained in
Maryland on high res levels and then use
them everywhere else turns out you
actually can kind of use them everywhere
else we went to Yangon for example and
Sentinel imagery instead of NAIP imagery
which is 10 meter resolution so totally
wrong and yet we were able to fine tune
that area relatively easily with a tool
but in general you'll have a problem
where the features that the mall is
extracting are really suited to the
terrain where you train this and not to
the new terrain so instead you could do
one supervise pre training and one of
the things we were playing with is let's
to build an identity function using a
neural network which we know doesn't
work the human networks can't learn
identity function because they
immediately get confused by correlate
correlations in the input data so they
started learning features that describe
these correlations but that's what we
actually want in a new area we want to
learn what is called how to basically
learn sufficient statistics that explain
the input and then map these sufficient
statistics to the output so Eli was
playing with things like can you give an
Apache can you predict what the patch
shifted by 15 meters looks like or
things like that and so we can use these
features then in the tool or for
training with low res labels then
spatial examples which are kind of
described to a certain extent then the
other thing is clustering models neural
networks actually don't really cluster
data they trash hold it but they don't
really compare input features and so we
have develop this overlap clustering
method which is simply going over the
image with or by moving a window and
clustering everything inside the window
and changing parameters of the clusters
slowly so that's why you can get
clustering of features or colors and
that can be better it especially in
terms of getting these sharp features
that GIS people like units will actually
create these blurry features in the end
and then there's a lot of these meta
learning approaches so if we know that
we're building these models so they can
be over trained later in the new area
should we just how do we do it should we
stop early in our learning or should we
should we actually learn it using a
metal learning approach so that we're
learning the core method that's easily
adaptable using the top two layers and a
variety of things like that and it's
been an hour so I'm gonna stop here
any more questions
[Applause]
sorry for any questions no I know you'd
mentioned that human knowledge is being
used in the form of labels of big labels
for pixels right yeah but I worry for
other source of human knowledge such as
you know rows are often connected
thickness can be useful as well to
assist with the yeah that would be nice
we have to change the interface one of
the problems we had is that we're not
really user interface people so so we
did the most simple thing that we can
and we're also thinking we can count
things in terms of click to compare
better but obvious you can have better
interfaces here where you can have
bigger brushes or you can make a stroke
so one of the things we were thinking
about is if you allow people to do
strokes or put pixels in the line can
you then can the model also build the
theory of mind of the human and say well
let me see what that means let's try
different things like how far am I
supposed to go from these these pixels
and believe that it's all the same label
so you can fine-tune those things as
well they'll be very exciting actually
if it worked the that you can kind of
feel that the machine is learning from
you really have you thought about like
using lidar data so GIS has like you
know very they're starting to have like
one meter resolution for 25% of us and I
think five meter for almost all of the
US and we know in the vision community
that depth usually generalized as well
yeah so a lighter lighter would help a
lot we haven't done it yet to be keep
talking about doing it but and we should
it will help a lot with buildings for
example it can help with trees can
resolve the shadows on the roads for
example shadows on the roads are a big
issue with these models
yeah extra data is always good because I
think the water especially really stands
out
yeah yeah we will be getting some this
was NAIP imagery but we will be getting
some satellite data from Planet and from
Airbus well Airbus is drones but we will
experiment with different things but
there's always always an issue with the
new terrain just looks different it's
just different water different roads
different different fields and so on so
I think it's quite possible that while
that map of the United States at four
classes that I showed you somebody's
gonna make a much better next year will
make not much better and maybe that
problem is gonna be solved there will
always be open problems with new labels
new areas new input imagery and so on
how much does the label how much values
in the coast label against so we don't
it seemed that at one point seem like
these fine labels a few fine labels are
enough but then qualia was playing with
this with wetlands in New Orleans using
or Louisiana using just a very simple
heuristic how to use an Allsteel labels
and that helped quite a bit and I'm
guessing it really depends on the on the
images did you have a sense for how the
people were choosing points to label ah
yeah we started looking at that and what
we found was that those who retrained
often we're doing better in general
because we allow people to test the
model but also to choose when to retrain
the whole thing was kind of organized
with very low computational cost just
because that was the idea for our
collaborators that they wouldn't spend
much money and so they can't really see
the the effect immediately on the until
they asked for it so they have to be
trained to see and that helped the other
thing is that users typically didn't go
for try to balance the labels have
of each and scattered across different
areas going to the I'm when I do it I go
to the area that looks different from
the area that I've just tested and I
come back later to check what happened
so those are the behaviors and the other
thing is that the best users actually do
not correct mistakes only like they will
actually click on on a road but then it
will say well I'm sure you're gonna now
be confused so they will also click on
the water and say this is water though
so so that those sort of things and then
we want to do some kind of an analysis
but we want more data to to see whether
we can maybe predict based on the the
pixel levels when people looking at that
image that I showed you of where people
worked looks a lot like an attention map
like the you know visual attention map
like what what the users are drawn to
and also we know that users are not
optimizing for accuracy overall accuracy
even though we told them that that's the
goal they they want cities to look good
the roads to look good defined features
to look good and then they want the big
features like a big field to be another
most of the field is fine but the
boundary who cares so so they have this
sort of a distorted view of the whole
thing so the things that they care about
is not quite the same that's just mean
accuracy difference in in performance
between the best user and like the
median user I gives you an opportunity
for maybe teaching teaching teachers to
do a better job yeah yeah that's what
sort of Andy wants to run more
experiments along those lines there the
question is is it just more time that
people need is it they didn't care I
mean those things we have to work out
and then the other question is is it
that some people are very good at fine
tuning the model up to here and then
they stop Blake for example spends too
much time in one small area right here
just perfection is there and then there
are people were just all over the place
so this is fine with me I don't care
about these details so there may be like
and that person should work together I
don't so those are the sort of things we
want to explore as well did you look at
so after they find your model on one
tile
you've looked at applying it to another
tile and does that do better than the
pre-training model or is it useless
actually uh Caleb you did that right
he's better than baseline but kind of
drops off after a while we could it'd be
kind of interesting like like what tiles
should you have the bulwark on for one
but then can you learn what adaptation
is happening I don't know if that's
allure no that's like I've made a
learning thing like learn how to adapt
for a new tile given a bunch of examples
of adaptations for other girls yeah yeah
we have to you have to look at that can
we predict just by appearance of the
tile what we should do how we should
start with even which base model to
start with copy another model and the
other approaches are if a lot of work
has already been done
the user can can come to a tile and just
flip through through a few different
models and say I'm going to start with
this one all of these things we have to
we have to try one thing I didn't show
you the tool but when you see the tool
then you sort of get the sense of the
scale of the problem that all of these
things are not like running one more
experiment over the weekend so this is
the tool that we have and so this is the
United States and this is where we
trained so you can click and get a
prediction
if the shrubbery jumpers yeah so here it
goes
and it works well in Chesapeake and then
if you zoom out you see how tiny that
place where it works is and then you go
to Florida and then you can see this is
totally different I mean you have to
spend some time thinking about what what
this is I guess the best way to call
these wetlands I guess and so here
you're gonna get a few predictions and
see thinks it's a forest it's the best
low vegetation it's probably wetlands
and then if you go to Arizona or Texas
totally different terrain different
images so so what I'm saying is that
that task is large so all of these ideas
are great and we'll have to prioritize
somehow unless somebody also wants to
help out which will be great but these
experiments going to take time also get
to fine segmentation as a human will do
it oh yeah sure we could actually train
that's the other things we were talking
about never did fully although one
person experimented with it a couple
years ago the the month resolution
approach and actually Caleb wanted to
try one using the quadtree
representation of the images and that
might help with draughts for example
roads are very long so from up here you
can detect the road more easily than
when you zoom in all the way so you can
be a guidance
all right let's thank the speaker
[Applause]
you